breaking news from overnight and a
development in the hunt for a missing
Aristocrat the couple sparked a
nationwide police Hunter after they went
missing with their newborn baby they've
now been found and arrested but police
say the baby is missing
and a search is underway uh Saba has got
more for us now in Brighton what on
Earth's going on there good morning
good morning K well as you say Constance
Martin and Mark Gordon have been spotted
in Brighton not too far from where we
are by a member of the public just last
night down the road from here before 9
30 p.m they were subsequently arrested
and are in police custody but here's the
main thing their newborn child who was
with them and had been spotted with them
is now missing and a major police
operation to find their child is
currently underway as I'm sure you can
see behind me now originally this was a
missing person's operation for the
family of three who were who have been
cited up and down the country at first
in Liverpool in Essex and South London
and also in East Sussex now the police
are saying that if members of the public
have any information that they should
urgently come forward because they have
serious concerns for the child's welfare
who they believe uh was born just a
month ago and they're urging people to
phone 999 as soon as they can if they
have information yeah this baby
um less about a month old as you said
um and it's not with the parents they've
been traveling up and down the country
the police must be desperately worried
about what's happened
absolutely they are and they at the
moment there's not a huge amount of
information they can say but from
speaking with them earlier they did say
that extensive searches are going on in
the area from where the couple were
spotted last night just before 9 30 p.m
and as soon as we have any further
updates we'll let you know